natürlich willst eigentlich bist du das
es sieht doch ein blinder dass lena an
die interesse hat
und wegen georgia
mach dir darüber keine gedanken es läuft
zu du hast uns hierher geschleppt nur
weil du hier band treffen willst
nein das ist nicht wahr ich wollte mit
euch einen ausflug machen und vielleicht
werde ich dann sogar wenn über den weg
gelaufen
woher weißt du denn überhaupt das ja
hier ist er hat mir in einer sms
geschrieben dass er hier irgendwo einen
job hat deswegen hast uns die ganze zeit
mit der museumsmeile genervt tut mir
leid also offensichtlich mehr als das
ich frage mich nur was passiert wenn die
beiden fluglinien
das ist er mit giorgios ich glaube sie
hat gerade einen alten bekannten
getroffen
sollen wir schon mal weiter gehen na gut
dann warten wir hier auf sie wo gehen
wir denn als nächstes hin
ihr handy
schön vor
danke mag das ist also band
wolltest du in ihr treffen für seine
wege